willkommen zu aktuellen Vorlesung zur
letzten inhaltlichen Vorlesungen die
sind Semester
wir kommen wirklich mit großen Schritten
auf das Ende hinzu und zu feiern des
Tages werde ich Ihnen das begriffsnetz
mal nicht präsentieren kennen sie ja
sowieso auswendig ne nächsten Montag ist
die Klausur ist ja ganz klar ich möchte
aber noch mal wiederholen auf das
Problem der Irrationalität eingehen und
zwar der Rationalität im Kontrast zu
Rationalität und zu a Rationalität wir
hatten das ja auch schon mal diskutiert
am Beispiel der Moralität da hatten wir
ja auch solche Phänomene wie Moralität
Amoralität im Kontrast zumalität ja da
möchte ich noch ein bisschen was
nachliefern ich hatte das Gefühl letztes
Sitzung hatten wir schon guten Zugang
gefunden zu diesem Problem ist ein
Problem aber es gibt noch viel mehr zu
sagen und da möchte ich natürlich wie
immer auch Donald Davidson eingehen den
Klassiker
der praktischen Philosophie ein
wirklicher moderner Klassiker und der
sagt die Möglichkeit von Irrationalität
hängt zu einem hohen Grad von
Rationalität ab also es ist nicht so
dass Irrationalität irgendwie so
verstanden werden muss dass der
Rationalität überhaupt nicht am Platz
ist also irgendwie gar keine
Rationalität das wäre Irrationalität und
wir müssen von der a-rationalität
Irrationalität unterscheiden das
Irrationale sagte ist nicht bloß dass
nicht rationale wir würden sagen dass
irrationale das außerhalb des Bereichs
des rational liegt sondern
Irrationalität ist ein Versagen
innerhalb des Hauses der Vernunft also
Irrationalität kann nur dort stattfinden
wo schon Rationalität am Platz ist das
sagte auch in einem anderen die Taten
nämlich hier ohne Rationalität keine
Irrationalität ganz spannende
Erkenntnis wo wir wirklich auch als
Philosophen und Philosophen
auch andere
Wissenschaftlerin Wissenschaftler
zum Erstaunen bringen können und ich
bringe gleich noch ein Beispiel aus der
Evolution Biologie die das belegt und
naturur Sachen blinde Kräfte gehören
nicht zur Kategorie des Irrationalen
sondern zur Kategorie des
nichtrationalen als irrationales und
nicht rationales oder irrationales
müssen wir von unterscheiden
so jetzt möchte ich noch ein bisschen
konkreter werden damit sie sich da was
vorstellen können Irrationalität setzt
eine gewisse Form von Rationalität
voraus man kann sagen eine entwickelte
Rationalität eine irgendwie schon
vorhandene Rationalität voraus warum wie
kann man das jetzt genau zeigen wir
können uns nämlich nur dann irren wenn
wir zuvor Hypothesen aufgestellt haben
sprich Urteile gebildet haben die
falsifiziert werden können also was kann
denn überhaupt falsch sein ja kann es
falsch sein dass ich meine Hand gerade
hebe kann das falsch sein
eigentlich muss man dann fragen was ist
eigentlich was kann eigentlich wahr sein
nur das kann falsch sein was auch wahr
sein kann oder nur das kann wahr sein
was auch falsch sein kann gibt es eine
Geschichte der Philosophie eine
riesendebatte drüber was überhaupt
Wahrheit ist ich mache oben rechts in
den Youtube und links zu einem Seminar
von mir rein wo ich mal ein ganzes
Semester lang nur die Frage aufgeworfen
hatte was es Wahrheit da reichen
eigentlich ein Semester gar nicht das
müsste man eigentlich das ganze Leben
lang müsste man sich das Fragen
jedenfalls die heutige Philosophie ist
der Auffassung das war und falsch nur
Urteile sein könnten nur Sätze die was
behaupten also nur wenn man ein Urteil
fällt über etwas Urteil kann Wahrheit
oder Falschheit überhaupt im Spiel sein
im Mittelalter dachte man
Dinge könnten wahr oder falsch sein zum
Beispiel hatten da Philosophen die These
vertreten das Messing ein falsches Gold
sei also Messing würde uns als Ding als
Metall darin täuschen wollen vielleicht
sogar Gold zu zeigen also der Fehler der
Irrtum war da sozusagen im Ding und in
der neueren Zeit kommt man eher dahin
und sagen der Irrtum der liegt nicht in
den Dingen sondern liegt in uns in
unserem verbaut auf jeden Fall falsch
halten wir irren uns über die Welt die
Welt ist weder war noch falsch Wahrheit
oder Falschheit kommt es dann ins Spiel
wenn es um Urteile geht die der Welt
entsprechend oder nicht entsprechend
also es ist ganz wichtig es geht hier in
der Regel um Urteil oder hypothes
und jetzt kann man mit Bezug auf die
Frage nach der Rationalität sagen das
Bilden von
falsifizierbaren Hypothesen wie man zum
Beispiel auch in der kurwissenschaft tut
Naturwissenschaft macht man Experimente
um seine Hypothesen zu weil sie fixieren
verifizieren geht ja das wissen sie alle
verifizieren kann ich empirisch kein
Urteil weil ich nicht wissen kann was
die Erfahrung bringt ich kann es nur
falls infizieren und dann eine neue
Hypothese entwickeln das heißt indem ich
eine Hypothese Bild oder Urteil Fälle zu
einem Urteil komme was war oder falsch
sein kann aber ich komme natürlich nicht
beliebig zu einem Urteil sondern ich
komme mit guten Gründen zu einem Urteil
sonst würde ich ja nicht urteilen ich
urteile ja eigentlich erst dann wenn ich
mir wirklich Gedanken machen kann es
gibt natürlich Leute die urteilen zu
vorstellen ist natürlich auch ein
Problem aber angenommen ich habe jetzt
Gedanken gemacht und komme zu einem
Urteil Urteil das XY der Fall ist
man nennt es häufig auch proposition
Präpositionen sind Sätze die einen
Wahrheitsgehalt ein Wahrheitsanspruch
erheben also man kann diese Sätze sich
auch vorstellen mit irgendwelche Komma
das also ich glaube dass ich denke dass
ich fühle das und alles was in diesen
das Teil reinkommt das ist dann die
Präposition und die Präposition kann war
oder falsch sein
und wenn wir jetzt eine Präposition
bilden oder Hypothese bilden also die
Hypothese sei jetzt mal das sich die
Sonne um die Erde dreht das sei jetzt
mal meine Hypothese dann kann natürlich
diese Hypothese warte falsch sein diese
These man kann auch sagen Thesen sind
Urteile Thesen Thesen können warte
falsch sein
darum geht es jetzt erstmal nicht
sondern es geht darum dass ich um
überhaupt eine solche Hypothese zu
bilden oder ein Urteil zu fällen
schon Rationalität brauche also eine
falsifizierbare Hypothese oder Urteil
oder was auch immer zu bilden ist
bereits ein rationaler Prozess sie
kennen das vielleicht schon alle aus der
Logik wenn ich jetzt sage wenn A dann B
wenn jetzt aber praktisch a ist und
nicht B
dann ist die Hypothese widerlegt dann
habe ich mich rational geirrt ich habe
eine
Konsequenz Aussage getroffen
wenn AFB
und jetzt ist aber der Fall aber nicht B
sie könnte es mit beliebigen Hypothesen
machen und dann so sagt die Logik ist
die Hypothese wieder legt dann habe ich
mich geirrt ich dachte wenn immer wenn
er dann B jetzt war a können sich
beliebiges vorstellen
aber BK nicht und dann muss ich mir
eingestehen ich habe mich geirrt weil
wenn ich war ein wahres Urteil gefällt
hätte dann hätte auf A B folgen müssen
jetzt war aber auch und es kam nicht B
ich habe mich geirrt das ist mag traurig
sein aber das schöne daran ist auch wenn
ich mich geirrt habe kann ich doch aus
der Tatsache dass ich nicht geirrt habe
schließen dass ich wenigstens rational
dabei war das heißt selbst wenn ich mich
irre heißt es nicht dass ich irgendwie
irrational oder irrational bin sondern
auch wenn man das jetzt Irrationalität
nennt ich habe mich geirrt bin ich dir
noch auf eine Weise mit der Rationalität
verbunden nämlich darin dass ich
überhaupt Urteile die falsch sein können
bilden konnte das heißt so gesehen ist
Irrtum eigentlich eine Auszeichnung
nicht alle Lebewesen können sich irren
sie kennen den Satz irren ist menschlich
der meint eigentlich was ganz anderes
schwer jeder Mensch irrt sich mal man
kann aber auch irren ist menschlich so
verstehen dass irgendeine Auszeichnung
des Menschen ist also nicht alle
Lebewesen können sich irren damit wir
uns irren können müssen wir schon
irgendwie eine gewisse ausgezeichnete
Form von Rationalität besitzen die sich
ihren kann und das ist glaube ich ganz
interessant das ist nicht so trivial das
heißt wer sich irrt ist nicht dumm
sondern eigentlich intelligent weil er
eben Thesen formulieren muss die
überhaupt falsch sein können
ich würde sogar so weit gehen das ist
ein bisschen pointiert Irrtum ist eine
Form von Intelligenz oder Irrationalität
ist eine Form von Rationalität oder
andere Irrationalität zeigt sich das
Rationalität irgendwie schon so im Spiel
sein muss
genau ich nehme jetzt gerade noch auf
also ich muss immer sagen weil man sie
nicht hört aber eine Frage ob das jetzt
auch für die Klaus wirklich natürlich
selbst wenn sie null Punkte haben wenn
sie sich bei allen Fragen geirrt haben
sollten würde ich ihnen drunter
schreiben machen Sie sich nichts draus
sie haben damit bewiesen dass sie
rationale Wesen sind
ja also keine Sorge
allerdings muss ich dazu sagen
Irrtum zu begehen ist gar nicht so
leicht wenn sie irgendwie sinnloses Zeug
drauf schreiben was was gar nichts mit
der Frage zu tun hat dann wäre ich nicht
mehr bereit ihn ein Irrtum zuzugestehen
dann würde ich im allerschlimmsten Fall
würde ich dann ihnen drunter schreiben
das war nicht mal irrational das war
irrational also das war das
allerschlimmste alles glaube ich nicht
also ich schaffen es auf jeden Fall
irrational zu sein das traue ich allen
zu
irrational das wird dann schon starkes
Stück da müsste ich mir selbst Gedanken
machen ob ich die Vorlesungen falsch
gegeben habe das würde alles natürlich
auf mich immer zurückfallen ja egal was
sie machen es fällt alles auf mich
zurück als du also Sie können ganz
beruhigt sein ja und jetzt möchte ein
bisschen konkreter werden wenn man das
mal an auf die Evolutionstheorie
es ist in der Forschung anerkannt dass
Irrtum nicht nur von menschlichen
Lebewesen sondern auch vielleicht bei
höhere entwickelten Leben lesen ziemlich
wichtig ist sie kennen alle das Prinzip
von Trial and Error natürlich muss man
jetzt hier bei trial immer hineinfügen
damit Sie wirklich Irrtum sein kann
bewusster Versuch und nicht nur so
wahllose Mutation ne so kann man
natürlich Evolution auch verstehen also
wahllose Mutation und irgendwo geht
nicht mehr weiter und dann mutiert seine
andere Richtung das ist natürlich kein
Irrtum hat Evolution wird natürlich in
dieser Hinsicht nicht sagt zumindest die
moderne Naturwissenschaft da steht kein
Bewusstsein dahinter ja
es heißt wir müssen das schon ein
bisschen anders verstehen also
Fortschritt lässt sich nur dadurch
erreichen dass wir uns methodisch irren
und aus unseren lernen und nichts
anderes macht die Naturwissenschaft die
Naturwissenschaft zu sagt ein Sprichwort
ist Irrtum auf den neuesten Stand
gebracht ne in 50 Jahren wird die
Relativitätstheorie nicht weil sie
fiziert sein vielleicht aber sie wird
aufgehoben sein einer viel größeren
umfassenderen Theorie wird als alleinige
Theorie so nicht mehr den Wahrheit sagen
das heißt moderne Naturwissenschaft
versucht immer Hypothesen zu bilden und
die methodisch geleitet durch
Experimente durch ganz viele Überlegung
zu falls Sie fizieren also Punkte
herauszufinden wo sie sich nicht mehr
bewirkt um einen Schritt nach vorne zu
gehen und das würde zeigen
durch rationales
Phänomen braucht unbedingt das Moment
des Irrtums ohne den Irrtum ohne die
irrtumsmöglichkeit kann moderne
Naturwissenschaft gar nicht
funktionieren sofern wir das Prinzip der
fallsifikation aufgeben brauchen wir gar
nicht mehr empirisch zu arbeiten das
ganz wichtig man muss sie sich getrauen
Hypothesen zu formulieren die müssen
begründet sein wir müssen aber offen
sein anzuerkennen dass diese Hypothesen
falsch war wenn wir das jetzt wirklich
eingestehen und nicht hinterher die
Experimente Stöhnen oder irgendwie
ausführen gibt es ja auch leider ja
damit gewinnen wir nicht ja sondern wir
sollten dazu stehen wir haben uns geirrt
und der nächste Schritt wäre wie kann
ich meine Hypothesen modifizieren im
Licht des Irrtums um sie vielleicht das
nächste mal nicht so an die Wand laufen
zu lassen das ist der Witz also man muss
sagen um vollständig rational sein
Irrationalität immer mit einbezieht und
zulassen aber eben nicht daran zu
Realität es ist ganz wichtig gibt seine
Forscherin Joel Prost
eine Naturwissenschaftlerin die die
These aufgestellt hat Zitat die
Möglichkeit des Irrtums stellt ein
bedeutsamen Schritt in der Evolution dar
diese Möglichkeit wie auch die Fähigkeit
im inneren Zustand zu verändern wenn der
Irrtum einmal aufgedeckt wurde ist
jedoch begrifflich an die Fähigkeit
gebunden geistige Repräsentation zu
bilden das heißt wir müssen ein Urteil
fällen können Urteile repräsentieren zum
Beispiel Vorstellungen Begriffe
repräsentieren das heißt irren können
sich nur Lebewesen die die die Welt
geistig repräsentieren können die
Sprachvermögen haben oder rudimentäre
Sprache die Vorstellung hat die Begriffe
haben nur dadurch kommt eine Differenz
oder eine Bindung ein Bezug des
Geistigen Welt zustande der falsch oder
wahr sein kann also nur diese Differenz
der repräsentationalität Repräsentation
heißt eigentlich nur Abbildung oder
Widerspiegelung oder Vertretung nur in
dieser
vertretungsrelation des geistigen zur
Welt nur aus dieser Differenz heraus
kann überhaupt Irrtum entstehen und das
zeigt eben wenn wir mentale Gehalte
haben mentale Repräsentation müssen wir
intelligent sein nicht jedes Lebewesen
ein Regenwurm hat keine mentale
Repräsentation von der Sicherheit nicht
beim Menschenaffen mit Sicherheit die
haben sicherlich rudimentäre Form von
geistigen Repräsentation deswegen könnte
man die These vertreten das durchaus
auch Menschenaffen
können und deswegen eine Form von
arzneimittalität besitzen bis dahin
wollte ich hier mal vortragen und jetzt
können wir darüber noch ein bisschen
diskutieren
ja wir haben gesehen Rationalität ist
eine Form von Normativität
Irrationalität können wir vorwerfen im
Sinne eines Fehlers wir können sagen du
hättest es aber wissen können wenn du
nur genug nachgedacht hättest also
Irrationalität ist jetzt nicht
kontradiktorisch der Rationalität
entgegengesetzt sondern es ist ein
Scheitern im Hause der Vernunft
und da gehen natürlich auch immer wieder
rationale Momente mit allen z.B geistige
Repräsentationen gewisse logische
Schlüsse und so weiter und sofort
sicherlich auch einige Erkenntnisse
müssen in Irrtümer eingehen ähm damit es
schon mal sein können und Irrtümer haben
wir gesehen können auch verschiedene
Ebenen stattfinden Newton hatte sich auf
einem höheren Niveau geirrt als ich in
meiner Mathematik Klausuren der fünften
Klasse sind beides immer aber wir würden
eigentlich irgendwie uns irren sage ich
jetzt mal diese Irrtümer einfach
einfach so zu identifizieren also irrt
schon mal Irrtum ist nicht gleich Irrtum
könnte man sagen jetzt möchte ich auf
das heutige Thema eingehen heute geht es
um die Zukunft der praktischen
Philosophie zum Abschluss unserer
Vorlesung und da geht es konkret um
praktische Philosophie und Digitalität
und der Digitalität versteht die
digitale Lebenswelt also unser Handeln
unter den Bedingungen der digitalen
Technologie die nahezu alle Bereiche
betrifft ein Bekannter Oxforder
Philosoph Luciano floridi hat davon
gesprochen dass sie ein Online leben
also wir leben indem wir eigentlich
immer schon online sind und das nennt
der Online Live und es wird sicherlich
auch noch weiter zunehmen das heißt wir
fragen uns wie verändert die
Digitalisierung unserer handeln die
Bedingungen des Handelns und des
Handelns selbst wir bekommen konkretes
Beispiel handeln wir wenn wir
Computerspiele spielen
ist es eine Form von handeln
wiefern können Roboter und künstlich
intelligente Systeme wie zum Beispiel
Chat GPT gerade in aller Munde der
Chatbot handeln handeln die die machen
doch was und das was die machen das ist
gar nicht so dumm also ich bringe ihn
nachher ein Beispiel von diesem Chatbot
wir machen immer langweilig da habe ich
immer eine Frage gestellt und jetzt
gehen wir aber erstmal auf
Computerspiele ein also
Computerspiele aber auch das metaverso
kennen Sie vielleicht von Facebook
vielleicht haben sie sich mal so eine
Brille aufgesetzt Horizon world ich gehe
dann noch ein bisschen näher drauf ein
die Frage ob wir handeln im
Computerspielen hängt davon ab ob
Computerspiele Fiktionen sind Nationen
Illusionen
Simulationen virtuelle Realitäten äh wir
müssen schauen was sind eigentlich
Computerspiele
computerspiele sind auf jeden Fall in
unsere Lebenswelt eingedrungen sie sind
perversive Phänomen das heißt sie
betreffen ganz verschiedene Bereiche man
spricht heutzutage schon von
Gamification in der Hochschullehre
werden kleine Spiele eingesetzt gewisse
und so weiter die digital sind
Gamification ist das Stichwort also das
Spiel wird immer mehr in Ernst in
Anführungsstrichen Bereich eingeführt
sind nicht mehr nur eine nutzlose
Spielerei sind wirklich interessant es
gibt eine eigene Philosophie der
Computerspiele
und ich möchte Ihnen jetzt hier ein
bisschen was von der USK sagen dass die
Unterhaltungssoftware selbst Kontrolle
sie sehen allerdings schon an der
Titelgebung die USK versteht
Computerspiele nur als Unterhaltung und
ich glaube das trifft die Sache
mittlerweile nicht mehr ganz
computerspiele sind nicht mehr nur
Unterhaltung nicht mehr nur bloße
Spielerei und sondern
wir drücken uns im Medium das komplette
Spiel selbst auf und reflektieren
Wirklichkeit Entwicklung und Veränderung
alles in allen Gesellschaftsbereichen
angekommen jetzt will ich immer so ein
kleiner Evolutionstheorie Evolution des
Computerspiels vorstellen
das haben Sie sicherlich schon mal
kennengelernt hier das ist das Spiel
Pong ja von 1972 und jetzt kann man sich
natürlich fragen was passiert da wenn
ich jetzt mit meinem Controller dieses
Rechte
Stäbchen da hoch oder runterschiebe
handle ich da ist es eine Handlung was
passiert da wenn ich gegen Computer
Spiele das links seit mal der Computer
gegen die Spiele Handel der Computer
dann tut er was wusst gut er erfolgt
ganz weg also er will offenbar diese
Linke will dass dieses Bällchen dieses
digitale Bildchen hier nicht durchgeht
will das Vermeiden ja seine Absicht
dahinter gibt es andere Spiele wo ich
die Figur eine Spielfigur steuere kennt
jemand dieses Spiel wahrscheinlich sind
sie alle zu alt ich habe das natürlich
noch gespielt na das ist Commander King
Commander mit vier sogar meines Wissens
ja da steuern Sie auf zweidimensionaler
Ebene eine Spielfigur eine ganz nette
das ist der Commander Kinos ist ein Kind
ein kleines Kind was sein Eltern
entleucht ist mit einer Rakete ins
Universum als die mal nicht aufgepasst
haben und dann hat es mit solchen
schrecklichen Schnecken zu tun hier
immer ein kleines Häufchen hinterlassen
da muss man aufpassen dass man nicht
rein läuft dann gibt's andere Spiele wo
man dann eine 3D-Perspektive einnimmt ja
sowie eine ich Perspektive und sogar
eine Waffe vor sich haben ne bei der
Spiel kennen Sie vielleicht auch es war
lange Zeit indiziert er ist glaube ich
nicht mehr indizierte Wolfenstein 3DS
wurde indiziert wegen
verfassungsfeindlicher Symbole in dieser
Zeit ja für die damalige Zeit
unglaublich grafisch beeindruckend ja
gut hier ist es entscheidend die
Perspektive ist eine andere sie sind
selbst zu sagt darin und haben deine
Wache
dann gibt es noch andere Spiele wie
Quake die das in einer wirklichen
3D-Grafik realisieren konnten
Wolfenstein hat es so eine 2,5
dimensionale Grafik da wurde viel
simuliert mit verschiedenen Techniken
diese Spiel hier Quake was mir 1996 ist
vollständig polygonal 3D konstruiert
worden mittlerweile gibt es natürlich
noch viel bessere Grafik engines nennt
man das Grafikprogramme die Unreal
Engine 5 die sehr sehr hoch realistische
Schatten und
Lichtreflex erlaubt also hier sieht man
eigentlich gar kein Unterschied mehr zur
Wirklichkeiten diese neuen Energizer
was die anreal Engine 5 die gibt es seit
dem Jahr 2020 und jetzt gibt es
neuerdings eben auch noch das Phänomen
der
Online-Multiplayer Spiele wie zum
Beispiel World of Warcraft das ist
natürlich nicht das einzige Spiel und
jetzt kann man sie natürlich überlegen
das sind jetzt alles Avatare von
Menschen die dahinter stehen und spielen
man spielt Miteinander in der virtuellen
Welt
handeln wir inwiefern handeln wir wenn
wir Computer spielen oder im metabären
unterwegs sind wenn ich würde vor
crushcraft Spiele dann gibt's dort auch
Geld oder Gold und dieses Gold was es
dort gibt ist nicht nur eine
Spielwährung sondern dieses Gold das
kostet wirklich das Geld es ist objektiv
das ist eine Spielwährung das ist nicht
nur eine Simulation dementsprechend ist
vieles was ich in World of Warcraft
Touren real nämlich virtuell real so wie
eben Geld virtuell real ist nicht nur
eine Bluse 3 das Simulation sinkt also
entschieden davon ab was wir glauben was
computerspiele sind
in Horizon words ich weiß nicht ob es
jemand von ihnen schon mal gespielt hat
da braucht man hier so gespielt sage ich
jetzt ist vielleicht schon wieder eine
Engführung ob jemand schon Horizon
worlds erlebt hat müsste ich fragen oder
darin schon mal existiert hat oder
aufgetreten ist da gab es hier ein
Problem im November 2021 da wurde jemand
wirklich belästigt da wurde jemand
virtuell belästigt von Avataren weil
diese Avatare dem eigenen Avatar zu nahe
kamen ja das ist wirklich eine virtuelle
Form von Belästigung und jetzt hat man
eine persönliche Grenze um diese Avatare
herumgelegt diese virtuellen aber Tage
damit solche Form von virtueller
Belästigung nicht mehr vorkommen es kann
sich fragen ist es wirklich eine
Belästigung oder ist es nur eine
Simulation von Belästigung da wird doch
niemand wirklich belästigt na gut aber
man verkörpert doch diesen Avatar in
diesem Spiel ja wie sieht's jetzt aus
möchte ich hier sie animieren bei einer
Umfrage
mitzumachen handeln wir im Computerspiel
handeln wir wirklich oder ist es nur
eine bloße Simulation oder bloßes Spiel
kann man nicht wirklich von Handeln
sprechen ja wir haben also gesehen hier
in der Umfrage doch sehr viele sind der
Meinung es handeln und das ist spannend
ich denke mal vor zehn Jahren vor 20
Jahren wäre es noch anders gewesen diese
Stimmungsbild jetzt möchte ich noch mal
zum Abschied zum Abschied und Abschluss
muss ich schon sagen die Frage aufwerfen
inwiefern kann künstlich Intelligenz
haben wir haben es ja nicht nur mit
Computerspielen zu tun sondern eben auch
dankenswerterweise neuerdings mit Chat
GPT
sie haben mitgemerkt mitbekommen die
Prüfungsordnung müssen alle
umgeschrieben werden weil durch diesen
Chatbot den ich gleich noch
demonstrieren werde plötzlich
Hausarbeiten ein Kinderspielchen man
gibt ein schreibe mir ein Essay über
dieses Thema und der Chatbot spuckt
einem das aus und zwar nie dieselbe
identische Version wenn sie zweimal
dieselbe Frage eingeben den Chatbot
spuckte ihn immer was anderes aus das
heißt Sie können gar nicht nachverfolgen
auf diese Ebene jedenfalls ob es jetzt
ein virtueller Ghostwriter war oder
nicht wir müssen uns fragen wenn wir die
Frage stellen ob künstlichen Intelligenz
handeln kann Besitz künstliche
Intelligenz Gründe Rationalität
Intentionen Absichten eigentlich die
ganzen Begriffe die wir gelernt haben
hat sie einen Willen ist der Wille frei
ja solche Fragen müssen wir daran
stellen und jetzt bringe ich ihn mal das
Beispiel
diese Chatbots haben Sie schon mal
vielleicht wer von ihnen hat schon mal
den Chatbot ausprobiert
gute Anzahl als ich kann Sie nur
ermuntern machen sie das kostet nicht
und
passiert eigentlich nichts wenn Sie die
richtigen Fragen eingeben kriegen sie
eigentlich nur gute Antworten aus
meistens jedenfalls die geben
instruktive Antworten auf Befehle oder
Fragen die kaufen menschlichen Antworten
mehr zu unterscheiden sind es ist
wirklich so die Kreisen dabei auf
Milliarden von Daten von Sätzen von
Texten aufs Internet zurück dies nach
bestimmten Algorithmen also
Verfahrensweisen ordnen und selektieren
und zwar mit Hilfe von künstlichen
neuronalen Netzen da mache ich auch oben
rechts links dann rein so weiter
erläutern das Problem ist wir können
aufgrund dieser komplexen
Mechanismen die da stattfindet der
komplexen Selektionsmechanismen können
wir nicht mehr nachverfolgen wie der
Chat sozusagen seine Antwort kam wir
wollen aber wenn wir kommunizieren mit
anderen Menschen immer auch wissen wie
jemand zu seinem Wissen kommt gib mir
die Gründe dafür an dass du zu dieser
Aussage bekommst das macht der Chatbot
nicht der Chatbot gibt uns spuckt uns
ein Ergebnis raus
aber er kann dieses Wissen nicht
rechtfertigen weil die Verfahren so
dunkel so Park sind so vernetzt sind
wenn sich ein künstliches neuronales
Netz mal vorstellen hat es tausende
Millionen von Verbindungen und Millionen
von Feedback schleifen die sie gar nicht
mehr im Sinne der Gründe für ein
Argument interpretieren können das geht
nicht das liegt in der Technologie
begründet also es handelt sich könnte
man sagen bloß um eine simulierte
Kommunikation genauso wie man sich bei
Computerspielen fragen kann ob es sich
nur um simulierte Handlungen handelt
künstliche intelligente Systeme könnte
man sagen sind keine handlungsobjekte
die sich autonomen eigenständige Ziele
setzen sie müssen diese Handlungsziele
diese Zecke immer von außen vorgegeben
bekommen das wäre zum Beispiel ein
Argument dagegen ein Chatbot als ein
handelndes Wesen anzusehen es gibt
natürlich auch Argumente dafür
weil eben auch eine treffende
Kommunikation hinbekommen wird und eine
Selektion der Daten stattfindet ein
Urteil wird gefällt diese Maschinen
Fällen Urteile und auch das hat
irgendwas in Rationalität jetzt gebe ich
mal ein Beispiel mir war es langweilig
und ich wusste nicht was ich tun sollten
habe ich das einfach mal eingegeben den
Chatbot und es unten das grüne ist das
was der mir hier ausgespuckt hat also
soll neues Hobby anfangen so ein
bisschen rausgehen ich soll ein Freund
anrufen
würden sich Zoll mein Zimmer mal wieder
aufräumen ich soll ein Buch lesen und so
weiter und so fort das hat er
ausgespuckt und er hat einen neuen
Punkte präsentiert auf die Frage was ich
tun soll wenn mir langweilig ist wenn
ich jetzt hier unten auf re generate
response gekriegt hätte hätte mir der
Chatbot ganz andere Punkte ausgesprochen
nicht mehr neun nicht mehr genau die
irgendwas ganz anderes aber es wäre mit
Sicherheit auch irgendwie sinnvoll
gewesen also als ich mir das dann
angeschaut habe wurde mir plötzlich
bewusst dass mir es gar nicht mehr
langweilig ist weil ich jetzt weiß nicht
tun kann ja ich weiß nicht wie es Ihnen
geht aber ich fand das ziemlich
instruktiv ich fand das jetzt nicht
irgendwie banal und gekünstelt Stichwort
künstliche Intelligenz sind das ist
schon was was man finde ich ernst nehmen
muss das ist ziemlich sinnvoll was du
mir ausgespielt hat ja und da kann man
es natürlich weiter diskutieren ob das
jetzt eine Handlung war hat er jetzt
gehandelt der Chatbot hatte mit mir
jetzt kommuniziert oder nicht das sind
spannende Fragen darüber werden in der
nächsten Sitzung noch mal diskutieren